[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind wirklich eine grassroot
bewegung von unten ganz normale bürger
den bürgerbegehren bürgerentscheid
machen wollen und unser ziel ist es dass
die radwege deutlich besser werden in
frankfurt das vernünftige infrastruktur
bekommen dass wir eine massive
veränderung herrschaften was katastrophe
ist am hauptbahnhof ich weiß nicht ob es
da schon mal entlang gefahren sind ja da
fühlt man sich sehr unsicher aber auch
zum beispiel auf der eschersheimer
landstraße im unteren bereich überlegen
ring bereich da gibt es überhaupt nichts
ja da sind wir auch mitten auf der
straße werden dann schon schutzstreifen
radfahrstreifen jetzt immer mehr gemacht
und das finden wir toll das radfahrbüro
arbeitet das super ja aber viele leute
fühlen sich da trotzdem unsicher auf
diesen streifen wir wollen abgetrennte
sicher radwege für alle und dann werden
auch viel mehr radfahrer auf die
infrastruktur zugreifen
wir sind jetzt 23 10 14 in den
stadtbereich wenn es hochkommt anstanden
kopenhagen am 50 60 also sieht man im
endeffekt wo die latte ist für mich ist
eigentlich entscheidende infrastruktur
soll so sein dass 96 siebenjähriges kind
alleine im endeffekt in dieser
infrastruktur fahren kann und das haben
wir fast nirgendwo in frankfurt also
haben schon einige tausend
unterschriften sind ganz entscheidend
für uns dass wir bei den landtagswahlen
eventuell die entscheidende frage
stellen wollen sie unsere sieben
forderungen die frankfurt zu einer
fahrradfreundlichen metropole machen
wollen sie das oder nicht dafür brauchen
wir die unterschriften
jetzt machen wir eine ernste sache
eigentlich die radfahrerin den in
frankfurt unter aber wir haben auch ein
bisschen spaß wir fangen jetzt wird hier
in den main und werden gerettet und zwar
von gratis
[Musik]
unser bürgerbegehren rat entscheidet
frankfurt bis zum 26 06 bitte
unterschreiben auf unsere listen unsere
listen finden sie auf unserer
internetseite können sie selber
ausdrucken oder sie finden auch eine
google maps karte mit 100 verschiedenen
geschäften läden wo sie unterschreiben
können